[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
hoy nos acompaña en el estudio crimisulá
saca hopulú ella es secretaria de estado
de Francia para el desarrollo la
francofonía y la colaboración
internacional actualmente de gira por
varios países de la región incluyendo
Colombia Madame ministro señora ministra
bienvenida muchas gracias buenas noches
Me gustaría comenzar preguntándole Cuál
es el objetivo de surgir a por la región
y qué tipo de cooperación Busca Francia
con los distintos gobiernos de América
Latina sobre todo con esta Nueva Ola de
gobierno algo más a la izquierda que de
costumbre qué prioridades Comparte el
gobierno de Manuel macron con estos
gobiernos
vamos a medir como usted dijo Francia y
los países de América Latina tenemos una
muy buena relación no solo vine para
señalarlo sino también para reforzarlo
va a ser más
[Música]
hoy aquí en Bogotá estuve con las
autoridades y la sociedad civil y vi que
hay un anhelo de Francia así como
nosotros tenemos un anhelo de Colombia
compartimos valores comunes como la
democracia pero también llevamos a cabo
luchas comunes en la escena
internacional Como por ejemplo la lucha
contra el cambio climático la protección
de los bosques la protección de la
biodiversidad
la protección de Forest la protección de
la biodiversidad
también Creo que tal como usted mencionó
en esta Nueva Ola de nuevos gobiernos
están todos los elementos para que
podamos trabajar juntos
de asambla
más adelante hablaremos sobre la
biodiversidad pero quisiera que hablemos
ahora de Colombia Cómo apoya el gobierno
francés al nuevo gobierno de Gustavo
Petro en términos de desarrollo y
también en términos de ese proyecto de
paz Total que él quiere para el país
el ojo la famosa a través de
prisa a través de sus empresas Francia
es el primer empleador extranjero aquí
250 empresas francesas están instaladas
aquí son 150.000 empleos para los
ciudadanos colombianos
que son poco les toalla en Colombia
ese es un tipo de cooperación también
hay cooperaciones científicas con
intercambios entre los estudiantes
cuatro mil jóvenes colombianos estudian
actualmente en Francia 500 personas
están haciendo su doctorado entonces hay
una bastante importante a nivel
científico y además a nivel cultural y
también lingüístico tenemos Trece
alianzas francesas y cinco liceos
franceses en Colombia es un país
francófilo
[Música]
y en términos de paz Cómo apoyan
directamente a Colombia con este
proyecto de paz total total
desde el primer día Francia ha apoyado
ese proceso de paz que es un modelo
internacional como saben en noviembre el
presidente Majo recibió al presidente
Pedro durante el foro sobre la paz y le
reafirmó su apoyo y la reafirmación
me pregunta cómo primero a nivel
político apoyamos totalmente ese proceso
de paz total desde el consejo de
seguridad de las Naciones Unidas también
financieramente con financiaciones
importantes para el desarrollo a nivel
territorial y a nivel técnico con un
jurista que vendrá para ayudar con los
procesos de Justicia
[Música]
va a venir
o procesos de la justicia
hablemos ahora un poco sobre la amazonía
ahora con esta Nueva Ola de gobiernos de
izquierda la protección de la amazonía
vuelve a estar en el centro de los
proyectos políticos que hace Francia
para lograr esa protección de una
biodiversidad que es esencial para el
planeta cómo lo ves yo así te quites un
siervo la Planet
el presidente está muy comprometido con
la cuestión ambiental y en particular
con la cuestión de la amazonía en 2019
Cuando ocurrió ese gran incendio el
presidente se pronunció hizo una alianza
para la protección de la
amazoníamos por la protección de la
mayoría
por supuesto No es solo la amazonía sino
también los bosques de la Cuenca del
Congo son tres móviles
que nos hemos movilizado mucho por eso
porque sabemos muy bien que la amazonía
es por un lado una selva importante para
toda la humanidad capta el CO2 y por
otro lado tiene mucha biodiversidad
estamos trabajando juntos a nivel
internacional trabajamos mucho con
Colombia durante la cop 27 por ejemplo y
en la cop 15 para Elevar los están y
para evitar la fractura entre el norte y
el sur ante el norte
y ahora con los dos nuevos gobiernos de
Colombia y Brasil trabajamos juntos
sobre distintos temas para la protección
de la amazonía a través por la
protección de la
gestión quisiera detenerme en Brasil el
presidente macron Tuvo una relación
bastante difícil con Jair bolsonaro qué
se puede esperar ahora de la relación
bilateral con el presidente Lula y más
allá de Brasil vuelven a estar sobre la
mesa Los acuerdos con el bloque de
mercosur les
mercosurel
sobre la tabla
le relaciona a beca la relación con el
nuevo gobierno y el nuevo presidente es
muy buena hoy día ambos presidentes al
presidente Lula y al presidente mahon
hablando por teléfono apoyamos al país
apoyamos la democracia de Brasil pero
también todas las luchas que ha expuesto
el presidente Lula contra la
deforestación por la protección del
medio ambiente por la protección de la
amazonía
que presentaron Lula a presente contra
la deforestación por la protección del
Antiguo la protección de la mayoría a
los nota relación aloja entonces nuestra
relación Será muy fuerte porque ya era
una relación histórica y Seguiremos
trabajando creo que la ministra culona
irá a visitar Brasil se ha retomado la
relación otra vez es muy activa
y usted mencionó el tema de mercosur
como saben actualmente no podemos Apoyar
el acuerdo entre la Unión Europea y
mercosur Unión Europea
Por qué Porque se establecieron unas
exigencias climáticas y ambientales se
presentó una reglamentación ante la
Unión Europea contra la deforestación
importada es muy importante mantenernos
coherentes pero estoy convencida de que
vamos a avanzar con el presidente Lula
que se
estresante
Lula
muy bien Ahora hablaremos un poco sobre
la francofonía usted también es la
encargada de la francofonía para el
gobierno francés cómo avanza la
francofonía en América Latina y cuáles
son los proyectos del gobierno del
presidente macron en la región
durante mi visita de tres días descubrí
un anhelo de francés hay muchos
francófilos esta mañana fue a Eliseo
francés y descubrí que el 70% de los
alumnos son de origen colombiano
sí les daríamos francesa además tenemos
las alianzas francesas que también son
centros de intercambio cultural
malanga Natalia este también es mi caso
porque el francés no es mi lengua
materna pero siempre digo que el francés
Es una lengua de oportunidad Esa es mi
perspectiva con las autoridades vi que
también hay proyectos para que la lengua
francesa esté más integrada en los
cursos y es algo que apoyaremos Colombia
es un centro importante porque todos los
docentes de la región se forman
Seguiremos apoyando este anhelo de
francés
de la región tú les enseñó son Macy
volao va continuar
justamente a propósito de ese anhelo de
francés los estudios de France 24 Están
en Colombia me gustaría conocer su
opinión sobre una cadena como esta que
contribuye un poco a la difusión
cultural de Francia en esta región del
mundo qué piensa ahora que la cadena ya
es de 24 horas
[Música]
son el principio creo que es muy
importante lo que están haciendo sobre
todo por los principios del periodismo
ustedes un periodistas profesionales y
trans 24 está muy vinculado a la
libertad de expresión entonces a través
de su presencia aquí se transmiten unos
valores de prensa libre y de una
información precisa siempre me parece
fantástico estar en un país y poder ver
France 24 porque como dije me quedo con
la información de calidad
nos queda tiempo para Una última
pregunta señora
otro tema muy importante para usted son
los derechos de las mujeres Cómo ve la
situación de las mujeres en América
Latina y cómo puede ayudar Francia para
alcanzar esa igualdad que todos deseamos
la
hoy me vi con la vicepresidenta y
hablamos mucho sobre el tema de la
igualdad entre mujeres y hombres sobre
el acceso a la educación sobre todas las
medidas que hay que tomar frente a la
violencia contra las mujeres contra fama
suponemos que la famosa
creo que de nuevo Francia es un país muy
comprometido durante el primer y segundo
quinquenio el presidente lo convirtió en
la gran causa del quinquenio le ofrecí
mi disponibilidad para compartir buenas
prácticas por los derechos de las
mujeres por un mundo mejor de tu
cuatefam Puga mundo señora Muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
eran las opiniones
sigan ustedes con más información en
France 24 y en France 24.com
[Música]